[Music]
it's Amore day for Zendaya and Tom
Holland I just
put the
uh it's really all I
always that's the couple packing on the
PDA during a trip to Venice Tom and Z
cuddling up close at one point the
actress plants his sweet kiss on her
Bow's cheek I am blown away the pair
then explores the city on a romantic
boat ride Tom capturing the moment
taking pics of Zendaya and her beloved
Pooch nude it's just the beginning of
this really adorable uh romance that
we're watching kind of Bloom on camera
yeah and speaking of this isn't the
first time we've seen Tom and Z take
Venice together
it's the most perfect word in the world
Italians created it and I just
discovered it the lovebirds filmed part
of Spider-Man far from home in the
floating city
America
whoa what was my new superpower it's
like the anti Aloha I was born to say
this word you shot in Venice you shot in
London what has it been like to be on
this Whirlwind summer vacation while
you're working around the world in
Europe it was kind of cool it was
interesting the day we walked on set for
the first time it felt like we'd come
back from our summer break it felt like
Spider-Man 1 was our first year of
school and this was our second year of
school so it didn't feel like any time
had really passed the two are known to
trot the globe together yeah I know I
know but they also have fun Stateside
ahead of their Italian getaway they hit
up the NBA playoffs in San Francisco not
far from where Zendaya grew up Tom
Holland and Zendaya Tom Holland spinning
a web over there Spider-Man and before
the bay it was Sin City the pair hitting
up Usher's Las Vegas residency
[Music]
I think it's great to have that support
and that love around you because you
need that you know this isn't an easy
easy job so it's good to have
that to to free you up from it every now
and then yeah seems like these two are
soaking in all the free time they can
get together and maybe left a pizza
their heart in Venice
foreign